getting your Titan can easily change the
battle in titanfall 2 so that's why it's
so key that you get it fast and use it
effectively in this video I'll be
explaining to you the three different
ways to get your Titan faster in
titanfall 2 the number three is killing
pilots killing pilots will grant you
twenty percent towards your Titan for
every KO and fifteen percent for an
execution getting a headshot will also
add two percent to that twenty percent
making a 22-percent this is a this is at
the number three spot because pilots are
everywhere which is the name which is
basically the main enemy in the game as
you fight other players and there's
plenty of pilots around so it's easier
to get your Titan this way as well the
number two spot is by using the archer
rocket launcher hitting a Titan with
this rocket launcher will give you a
22-percent towards your Titan for every
hit you land as seeing as the Archer has
nine shots you can't go wrong with this
on your class the number one best way to
get your Titan in titanfall 2 is by
giving batteries to your teammates now
as I explained these top three choices I
will be showing gameplay is proof the
only problem with this one is is I don't
have proof to show you I looked up on
reddit and someone said that when you
rip out of titans battery you get sixty
percent and then if you give it to
another teammate you get the extra forty
percent to put into your Titan meter to
give you one full Titan just by ripping
out someone's battery now I did try this
in game for myself and I wasn't
recording at the time but I can confirm
that that is completely true you're just
going to have to take my word for it so
remember the number one way to get your
Titan quake is by giving batteries to
teammates and these are some great
options but what about game modes
because not everyone can just go up to
Italian rip out of the battery and in
fact escape without getting shot and
killed and giving it to a teammate so I
found out the better game modes for to
get your tight and quicker if you can't
just rip out a battery the two game
modes you want to be playing our cop or
capture the flag and am [ __ ] point
capture the flag when you pick up the
flag you will get ten percent towards
your Titan and foot and an extra thirty
percent giving you forty percent if you
were to deliver the flag back to your
base the second one is amped hard point
where you get ten percent for capping it
and an additional fifteen percent adding
up to twenty-five percent towards your
Titan for double amping the objective
and I remember playing ant hard point
the objective that you spawn at is
closest to you whether it's a or C so
you can get a fourth of your Titan
already at the start of the game and it
hasn't even been a minute I should be
showing you gameplay of the timer and am
card point the game starts at ten
minutes at the clock and I got Ronin
within with eight minutes and 49 seconds
on the clock so it took me a little bit
over a minute in 10 seconds to get my
Titan to spawn anyway if you did enjoyed
this video please leave a like I hope
you guys did enjoy comment if you guys
have any other ways of getting your
Titan faster kind of shared around a bit
shared this with any of your friends if
you want to that's completely fine with
me and subscribe if you're new I have
plenty more titanfall videos coming the
series is so much fun and I love making
these videos for all of you and I love
all the comments I've been getting from
all of you and it you know you know that
good stuff have a great day guys peace
out